Hi, there. I just read your page understanding. Right frequencies and it certainly shud's light on many things and many treatments. I benefited from right therapy over the past few years, going to go down.
I have been facing a systemic MRSA infection in NABX failed to address biomedical staff members that failed to perform adequate testing to diagnose.
What I have certainly going on appears that to have me from contaminated water supply here in Dallas, Texas.
Yeah, I'm having second thoughts. Now you mentioned the article frequencies do not diagnose disease. However, it does that also mean the frequencies diagnosed to eliminate pathogens do not determine the presence of those specific pathogens.
So let me just answer that question because I talk about in a lot of places that, you know, there's those different apparatuses that different practitioners use. Those little hand cradle things to diagnose. So it's running frequencies through your system and it's getting feedback on those frequencies and that it tells the machine what frequencies that person got feedback on.
And often those tools are used to diagnose and I caution people to not do that because just because you had a hit on a certain frequency doesn't mean that it doesn't mean that you have that disease.
So could it point to that possibly could it give you clues? Sure, but it doesn't mean that you have that disease. So I'm I'm very outspoken against using frequencies to diagnose you need to use standard labs you need to use standard proven therapies that can that could get to a diagnosis.
I'm not saying that you can't those tools and you can't use alternative things to give you clues to give you ideas, but I'd be very careful to not say, oh, you have, you know, mercury toxicity because it came back on your, forgot what those scans are, there's multiple different companies that have those.
It can give you ideas, but to say that you have mercury toxicity based on that scan, I think that's that's not good science. And I, you know, wouldn't necessarily say it's not practice, but I'd say that's not good practice.
And then this first is a very, very long question. So talking about H. Kylo right and immersive infection, certainly asking for the best help you can offer as it appears at both H. Kylo or immersive to have crossed the blood brain barrier.
Okay, can bacteria cross the blood brain barrier? Yes, absolutely. So even a healthy intact blood brain barrier bacteria can get across, but certainly there's probably very few people that have a healthy intact blood brain barrier. Remember, your blood brain barrier is made up of certain glial cells called astrocytes that literally wrap around the vessels that are going through the brain.
Protecting it from bad guys, chemicals, additives, you know, things that are certain that your blood oxidizing agents pathogens from getting across, but things because we're, we're, because we're exposed to so many toxins.
Those things can damage cells in our body in our blood brain barrier. Those astrocytes are not immune to damage. So they can be damaged. And then you have, you know, gaps in your blood brain barrier and things get across in the blood brain barrier.
That's been shown proven time and time again that that takes place. And remember for children, that's why I'm so against vaccines for kids is that, you know, before H3, they don't have a blood brain barrier. It hasn't even formed yet. So anything gets across the blood brain barrier because it's on there.
So, but yes, pathogens, MRSA, H. Pylori certainly can get across the blood brain barrier. H. Pylori, when it goes systemic, is a major player for a lot of bad things to happen.
So that's why I'm a big fan of using products like Burberry because Burberry is a great killer of H. Pylori.
Okay, so under the question, it is crucial that I know what needs to be done to fully resolve this sooner or the later as hours of treatment every day, only to a four time cannot go on and definitely please contact me.
So, okay, you can call our office. So, anyway, it's on this call. You can contact our office. You can schedule directly without contacting our office. We have a schedule now button.
Just go to that page and schedule a time with me. And if you've never had time with me before, you have to start with what's called a case review.
And as many documents as that you could send to support your issues that you might have, like pathology reports or blood tests and things that you've done recently can help you.
So, the more information that we have, the better that can be from where I can help you.